[Musique]
j'ai décidé que nous ne ferions que rire
aujourd'hui
c'est la maison du bonheur
quotidien c'est un c'est pas c'est pas
d'une émission de l'information ou de
journaliste au quotidien c'est un
amuseur parfois très drôle d'ailleurs je
dis pas
bonsoir et bienvenue chez les amuseurs
il ya qu à nous voir on est des sacré
rigolo nous sommes mercredi 13 avril
2022 bon d'abord quotidien
d'ailleurs c'est pas assez évidemment
des journalistes quotidien dans quel
acteur c'est pas des gens qui font du
divertissement mais ce sont des
militants et des militantes yves marie
le pen c'est ça la vérité les gens pour
nous mais vous le savez bien quand je
vous entends parler par exemple des
juristes de quotidien je me dis maison
en fait elle n'a pas changé c'est
toujours la même moi je pensais qu'il y
avait une nouvelle marine le pen mais
depuis quelques quelques mois et puis là
sur cette question désert vous savez ça
fait sept ans ça fait sept ans que j'ai
dit quotidien n'est pas
moi c'est une erreur de dire cela ou
c'étaient des tiers mais qu'est ce
qu'elle est ce qu un candidat ou une
candidate à la présidence de la
république peut dire qui est journaliste
qui ne l'est pas est ce que un président
de la république un exercice candidat
peut décider d émission dans laquelle il
y en a ne va pas répondre à une question
par une question c'est un procédé mais
cette malhonnêteté j'espère j'espère que
nous ne l'avons pas ici sur ce plateau
c'est tout j'espère parce que ça ne
correspond pas à nos valeurs comme on
dit je considère que c'est une émission
qui est une émission de divertissement
régis pas la saveur mais c'est vrai mais
je suis pas là
pas tous bien sûr aller mais je suis mal
mais je suis pas la seule je vais vous
dire puisque le syndicat national des
journalistes qui est pas
particulièrement proche de moi avait
refusé leur carte de presse aux
journalistes des deux quotidiens ya dix
ans à l'époque c'est le petit journal et
monsieur barthez et on n'a pas sa carte
de presse ne cherchez pas à créer on a
écouté les problèmes là où il n'y en a
pas avec le quotidien je crois que ça
fait sept ans que ça dure voilà donc je
veux dire on la cession servirait le
soudan est là dit il sont pas en âge
soir l'a dit mais l'a dit d'abord sous
la forme de la plaisanterie d'accord
était une plaisanterie exactement natra
tu ferais mieux de tourner sept fois la
langue dans sa bouche avant de causer
toi je te le dire aa et sportifs se
prononce en faveur d' emmanuel macron
dans une tribune publiée hier une
cinquantaine de footballeurs boxeur
basketteurs ou judokas appelle à faire
barrage à l'extrême droite au second
tour parce qu'ils se croient aux sports
fraternelle et inclusif c'est vrai que
je suis un peu lassé pour tout vous dire
de ces postures bon fraternelle et
récluse yves que nous nous engageons
pour éviter que notre nation place à la
tête une présidente qui incarne tout le
contraire la stigmatisation de l'autre
le repli sur soi le nationalisme et que
nous appelons donc à voter pour emmanuel
macron le 24 avril prochain il ya par
exemple en toi tu es là c'est
pas du tout bon madame le pen raconte
comme d'habitude des carabistouilles
vous traduirez même en en anglais alors
comment traduire carabistouilles pour
les confrères anglais quelqu'un une
traduction quelqu'un avec washington
google soit j'aurais tenté
carabistouilles bras ce que je trouve
mélangés
et je ne parle pas de mélenchon je veux
j'attends qu'on me dise de tweets mais
bon la soliste avec vous sont absolument
appeler ça du tout mais non vous
n'écoutez pas ça fait l'art entendre ou
d'écouter personne et vous êtes à la
virgule user samedi donc vous devriez
péter sellars
beaucoup de mots pour rien
verbiage oui le verbiage
[Applaudissements]